i actually have some good news to start
with today
um we have been sort of worried that not
enough people
in the united states in other countries
as well but we've been looking at the
numbers in the united states that not
enough people in the u.s would want
the coronavirus vaccine which would make
it
really difficult to get to the herd
immunity that
is necessary for life to really start
going back to normal in the context of
the pandemic but the good news
is that every single week the percentage
of americans that want the vaccine
and plan to get the vaccine and would
accept the vaccine
where it made available to them is going
up and that's excellent
that number is now at 71 71
of americans say they would get the
vaccine and remember that
just months ago only 40 percent of
americans wanted it and that crept up
to 50 60 63
about a month and a half ago and that
number is now at 71
and the poll that shows 71 percent
is from before joe biden and dr
anthony fauci received their first doses
over the last 36 to 48 hours
which hopefully will push interest in
getting the vaccine up even
further now the 27 percent
that remain hesitant about this vaccine
there's a few characteristics these are
a few different groups so
those who remain vaccine skeptical are
disproportionately
republicans disproportionately those
30 to 49 and disproportionately people
who live
rurally uh and disproportionately
uh black american who who are the most
vaccine
hesitant groups now the reasons why each
of these groups is hesitant about the
vaccine
differ some of the primary reasons are
fear of side effects fear that the
vaccine is
too new which can mean a lot of
different things but that that's the way
they described it
and among among black americans the
primary reasons for vaccine coronavirus
vaccine hesitancy
are general distrust of vaccines
and concerns that one could get
coronavirus
from the coronavirus vaccine now in
terms of
states i don't this is not super
surprising but there's some interesting
data points here based on data from the
ihme from a few days ago
the states where residents most want the
vaccine
are vermont new york minnesota
washington state california hawaii
virginia and colorado followed closely
by
sort of the rest of the northeast states
plus north carolina and a few others now
on the other side of this
the states where residents least want
the vaccine
um at the absolute bottom of the list
are mississippi arkansas
and wisconsin now i'm guessing that
there are
particulars about why wisconsin is there
i don't know if maybe
wisconsin has a number of different
religious uh groups and sects there
i don't know if there's one that is
overwhelmingly anti-vaccine
i'd be interested in knowing more about
that but mississippi arkansas and
wisconsin are the most uh the state's
most
at least interested in the coronavirus
vaccine followed by
a number of states like texas south
carolina georgia alabama
ohio indiana oklahoma kansas so there's
quite a lot long list in sort of that
lower but not
lowest range so bottom line
it's good that the numbers are up to 71
percent i do want to remind you the
vaccine is not going to be given to kids
anytime soon
so when we talk about 70 for herd
immunity we're talking about the whole
country
so 71 of adults wanting and getting the
vaccine eventually
doesn't get us to 70 percent of the
entire country we still would not be at
heard immunity but these are the best
numbers we've had
since the start of this thing and that's
good um the public campaigns
to say i got the vaccine and people
posting pictures
uh on on facebook and social media dr
fauci getting the vaccine etc that does
seem to be working
because getting a vaccine in the
abstract before anybody's getting it
is not likely to appeal to as many
people as getting the vaccine that my 12
nurse friends got and posted on facebook
about
and that's certainly helping now as of
this morning
777 000 americans
have received the first dose of the
vaccine
that's 0.23 percent of the u.s
population
it's a start but again un unless and
we're expecting to
unless we ramp up the number of vaccines
going out and
and being used to inoculate people every
week goes up
it's going to take a while it's going to
be a process now in terms of more
vaccines remember that currently in the
u.s
there's the pfizer biontech vaccine and
the moderna vaccines that have been
approved
the moderna vaccine is just now starting
to be given to people
and then we have the astrazeneca oxford
vaccine close to possible approval
and then behind that you've got the
novovax and johnson and johnson vaccines
moving ahead
pending results so in the end whatever
the polls say
start distributing it get it to people
keep the process moving forward and
we'll keep evaluating month to month and
really week to week now an important
note and i don't understand
this yet i've seen the data i don't i
haven't interpreted the data
um even though states have now
it's been several days uh and in fact
more than that
since uh states received their first
shipments
many states have only so far actually
used 10 to 15 of the vaccines that
they've received
now i express concern that we we don't
want to see
lots of vaccines just sitting around and
not being used and a lot of this is
getting the logistics up and running and
i understand that
but over time if if we are seeing that
states are
sitting on a bunch of vaccine with lack
of clarity
or or or um execution
in terms of actually getting it to
people that will be a concern and we'll
cross that that bridge
when we come to it but the urgency can't
be exaggerated another
3 400 people died yesterday of the virus
absolutely tragic numbers hey take a
minute to
check out our sponsor it's called just
egg
many of you know that over the years
i've made my diet more
plant-based for a variety of reasons
i've always loved eggs
and just egg is a great way to take a
food many of us love but make it a
plant-based
version just egg has all the protein of
eggs but it's made from
mung beans so it uses 98 percent less
water and causes 93 percent fewer carbon
emissions than a conventional egg
just egg cooks and tastes exactly like a
conventional egg i've tried it for
omelets scrambled eggs french toast
banana bread
pad thai even anything you'd normally
use eggs for
i actually think if i cooked something
for a friend without telling them
about just egg they wouldn't even know
the difference
you can find it in the egg aisle at your
grocery store or on amazon prime now or
instacart they also have a frozen
version which is perfect for breakfast
sandwiches
just egg check it out